guten tag philosophie ist die kunst die
eigene zeit in begriffe zu fassen
nicht nur diesem sinne sitzen im moment
einer der ganz großen philosophen
unserer zeit gegenüber awp authentizität
oder multikulturalismus die quellen des
selbst oder das säkulare zeitalter seit
mehr als 50 jahren versorgt uns der
kanadier charles taylor mit den
maßgeblichen stichworten und theorien
politischen denkens und trägt so die
suche nach einem besseren zusammenleben
immer wieder neu an es gibt gerade heute
viel zu besprechen herr taylor herzlich
willkommen zwei wilde täler eines der
großen themen dass sie derzeit
beschäftigt ist die krise der demokratie
nun kann man sagen es liegt im wesen der
demokratie in der krise zu sein oder
anders gesagt eine kristen demokratie
die nicht in der krise ist es gar nicht
lebendig ich denke das kommt der
wahrheit nahe
manche krisen konnten wir zwar
verhindern aber sie waren immer eine
gefahr die demokratie verspricht etwas
das im griechischen wort demos steckt
was so viel heißt wie nicht elite das
versprechen lautet auch wer nicht der
elite angehört kann sich einbringen und
bei entscheidungen mithelfen doch in
vielen demokratien ist es immer weniger
dafür die elite und verschiedenste macht
spiele gewinnen zunehmend an einfluss
der krisen sind daher ständig eine
realität wurde eine gefahr wenn wir
jetzt zehn jahre zurückschauen
beispielsweise barack obama will gelegt
in vier ländern ein demokratischer
aufbruch auch in den arabischen ländern
heute ist die situation recht anders
woran würden sie die krise die wir heute
erleben in den westlichen demokratien
festmachen
die westlichen demokratien städten
tatsächlich in der krise und wie sie
sagen gelingt es auch nicht neue
demokratien zu errichten aber sprechen
wir über die krise der westlichen
demokratien es ist gut mit barack obama
zu beginnen denn es schien als spräche
er von dieser krise seine kampagne stand
unter dem slogan yes we can
damit sprach er viele einfache bürger
westlicher demokratien an die den
eindruck hatten sie könnten nichts vor
sie litten unter allen möglichen
problemen und sah nicht wie sie
veränderungen in gang bringen können
dass sie so unglaublich stark auf diesen
slogan reagierten zeigt ihren großen
wunsch sich einbringen zu können
nehmen wir ein europäisches land wie
spanien
dort entstand aus den protesten die
partei podemos was dasselbe heißt jetzt
bekennen
ich denke unsere momentane große krise
beruht auf der tatsache dass von diesen
hoffnungen viel zu wenig übrig geblieben
ist
es gibt hier eine spezielle moderne
befindlichkeit in niklas luhmann mal auf
den begriff gebracht hat alles könnte
anders sein ich kann nichts ändern
das heißt eine individuelle ohnmacht im
angesicht einer gemeinschaft die nicht
so handelt wie es nötig wäre ja das
stimmt
die menschen haben das gefühl in einer
großen maschinerie zu stecken
der aufstieg des neoliberalismus für
mich der inbegriff des übertriebenen
glaubens an die märkte es gibt den
menschen den eindruck alles sei
vorgegeben nicht von einer person
sondern von diesem unpersönlichen
riesigen globalen markt dessen
mechanismen sie nicht verstehen und in
dem sie nichts ausrichten können
das drückt auf die moral der bürger und
wenn es nicht gut steht um die
demokratische moral und laufen die diese
tendenziell schlecht die anonymität der
strukturen dass es ein problem
gleichzeitig sehen wir eine
personalisierung des feindes die idee
dass ein politischer gegner ein feind
ist ist drängender geworden und auch die
brutalisierung des sprechens im
politischen diskurs worauf führen sie
das nicht damit müssen wir beginnen
sondern mit den rettern die überall
auftauchen wie donald trump der amerika
wieder groß machen
die personalisierung beginnt mit dem
neuen machthaber der verheißt uns mit
unseren fähigkeiten oder stärken zu
verkörpern wenn wir ihm folgen
damit verspricht er uns eine gewisse
macht
aber erschreckend ist das heutige
leadertypen wie salvini marie le pen
oder trump einen großen teil der
bevölkerung stigmatisieren und
anprangern
das widerspricht diametral der natur der
modernen demokratie die sich als
egalitär versteht die alle einbeziehen
und allen gleiche rechte zugestehen soll
diese demagogen wirken die zentralsten
demokratischen werte ab und sie
erreichen nichts damit denn sie haben
kein programm um ihre versprechungen
einzuhalten und die probleme zu
überwinden
das zeigt zum beispiel der handelskrieg
von trump der nirgends hinführt
sie haben keine lösung für die ursachen
hinter den problemen der menschen
prozent kann man das gefühl haben dass
diese person durch den kontrast durch
die gegnerschaft die sie betonen eine
art vitalisierung vornehmen das heißt
eine verlebendigung der demokratie die
vielleicht in zu viel konsens erstarrt
war
ja sie weg in die hoffnung auf eine neue
bewegung auch wenn das völlig
illusorisch ist können sie damit sehr
überzeugend wirken aussagen wie wir
machen amerika wieder groß oder wir
machen frankreich wieder zum land das es
früher war
wecken hoffnungen bei den bürgern sie
haben den eindruck sie könnten etwas
bewirken wenn sie mächtige leute wie
trump oder le pen wählen noch etwas
anderes sollte uns bewusst sein die
wähler glauben nicht singen an diese
populisten
sie sind vielmehr so verzweifelt und
wütend dass sie wenn sie schon nichts
gegen ihre probleme tun können
wenigstens denjenigen die sie dafür
verantwortlich machen eins auswischen
wollen
ein gewichtiger faktor ist also die wut
man muss nur schauen nach welchen
gesichtspunkten die amerikaner 2016
gewählt haben viele sachsen falls trump
es nicht schafft werden wir bernie
sanders wählen
es ist also nicht so dass sie transpromo
guthießen den absoluten höhe oder besser
tiefpunkt dieser verzweiflung sieht man
beim harten kern der gelb westen in
frankreich auf das angebot zu
diskutieren und eine lösung zu suchen
gehen sie gar nicht ein
wir wollen nicht diskutieren es gibt
keine lösung wir wollen einfach unsere
wut rauslassen wir sind das volk sind ja
sehr dunkle energie
er kann sagen ressentiments verzweiflung
fast bis zur selbstzerstörung wilder
mann weiß das sind keine lösung man
wählt sie trotzdem weil man gar keine
lösung er sieht ja stimmt das ist ein
erschreckender gedanke wie sie sagen ist
es ein selbstzerstörerisches verhalten
das aber viel nicht bewusst ist
wer im armuts gürtel um das appalachen
gebirge oder in denen von großer
arbeitslosigkeit betroffenen regionen
frankreichs lebt versteht wohl diese
unterschiedlichen beweggründe gar nicht
aber wenn man diesen menschen zuhört
spürt man ihre große wut und den drang
jene zu treffen die sie dafür
verantwortlich machen wenn wir diese
teilung der demokratie in sich selbst
beobachten da kann man sagen es gibt
eine achse die immer wichtiger wird die
achse zwischen land und stadt wo man hat
den eindruck die verzweiflung der
destruktion swiss muss vielleicht sogar
liegt auf dem land während die stadt
diese bewegung nicht gleichermaßen
mitmacht sicher spielt es eine rolle ob
man in der stadt oder auf dem land lebt
aber dieses phänomen hat er historische
gründe ausschlaggebend ist woher wir
stammen zudem einen fehler
früher war alles viel besser gewesen
in den usa werden die gründerzeit oder
der bürgerkrieg mystifiziert in
frankreich die revolution oder die
prinzipien die auf dem spiel standen in
deutschland ist es wahrscheinlich 1945
viele haben den eindruck wir hätten den
bezug zu unseren ursprüngen verloren
oder würden uns davon entfernen
in der politik ist es daher wichtigsten
was für eine geschichte man erzählt
obamas geschichte wie es in die zukunft
der propagierte eine perfektere union
der vereinigten staaten und berief sich
damit auf die verfassung sprach aber in
der vergangenheit unsere union war gut
aber wir müssen sie stetig verbessern
ja in zukunft sinn sein fallen qualität
party die sich auf 1774 beruft und sagt
wir waren freie amerikaner und müssen
diese freiheit zurück erobern
auch marie le pen und alle diese
bewegungen mystifizierung eine
vergangenheit in die wir nicht
zurückkehren können aber sie beharren
darauf sie wurden uns genommen und sie
müssen wir zurückkommen
es gibt ja einen politischen vordenker
der sozusagen der urvater dieses zurück
gewandten populismus ist jean jacques
rousseau
er ist auch so darstellt dass die
zivilisation den menschen entfremdet und
freier macht ein naturzustand auf dem
land imaginiert in dem wir wirklich frei
waren und der sagt wir brauchen einen
volonté générale einen populistischen
gemein willen der uns vor dieser
situation hätte ja in gewisser hinsicht
ist es eine rückwärtsgewandte geschichte
oder es bewusst vermittelt wir hätten
eine falsche richtung eingeschlagen wir
seien in einem naturzustand gewesen und
dann voneinander abhängig geworden
noch mehr wird aber von den medien ein
gemeinsamer wille heraufbeschworen der
wie ein blitz einschlägt
das ist eine weitere schreckliche
illusion die zum beispiel suggeriert in
der französischen revolution seien alle
vereint gewesen
das sieht man auch bei den gelb wissen
sie wollen das drama der französischen
revolution von 1830 und 1848 wieder
aufleben lassen
ja es ist eine art folklore die
suggeriert ein blitz würde einschlagen
und uns alle vereinen
das ist eine große illusion es ist für
mich interessant zu sehen dass sie sich
so weit von jean jacques rousseau
distanzieren weil sie selbst in ihrem
denken als politischer philosoph
jean-jacques rousseau eine zentrale
stellung ein
sie sind kommunitarismus haben ein ohr
und ein gespür dafür wie wichtig die
idee einer gemeinschaft auch einer
volksgemeinschaft sein kann und sollte
und nicht nur das ich denke dieser
wunsch nach anerkennung geht zurück auf
[Musik]
auch wenn alle sagen es gehe um hegels
prinzip von herrschaft und knechtschaft
und um johann gottlieb fichte aber diese
idee der anerkennung beziehungsweise der
fehlenden anerkennung findet man bei
russen bekam wenn ich davon abhängig bin
was sie von mir denken russo bezeichnet
das als versklavung ist das nicht
wirkliche anerkennung die spielerinnen
vor jemand anderer zu sein um ihre
anerkennung zu gewinnen
der wunsch nach anerkennung liegt dem
phänomen wohl oder übel zu grunde darum
kommen wir nicht herum wenn wir von
anerkenne oder anerkennungs mangel
sprechen da gibt es ja sagen wir mal
zwei große theorien die einen sagen
anerkennungs mangels ökonomisch er ist
monetär ich will in meiner
wirtschaftlichen existenz anerkannt
werden und dann gibt es ein zweiter er
sagt das ist kulturelle ich will in
meiner identität als kulturelles wesen
anerkannt werden muss so ist doch eher
ein identität theoretiker was uns in die
heutige zeit bringt diese wut ist das
eine kulturelle
oder eine ökonomische würden sie sagen
ich denke es geht um beides viele bürger
die diese machthaber gewählt haben sind
wütend weil sie sich in wirtschaftlicher
hinsicht vernachlässigt fühlt doch
leider oder glücklicherweise
funktioniert unsere gesellschaft nicht
wenn den menschen systematisch eine
gewisse identität abgesprochen wird
natürlich anerkennen die anhänger dieser
populistischen helden die identität
anderer nicht aber das ist in unserer
zeit nicht mehr tolerierbar
die menschen fordern dass man sie ernst
nimmt so wie sie sind
das geht auf russo zurück sie wollen
nicht mehr etwas anderes vorgeben oder
überhöhten standards entsprechen
daraus resultiert eine instabilität die
unsere moderne gesellschaft prägt und
wir müssen beiden anerkennungs
ansprüchen gerecht werden
die ambitionen wünsche und
lebensentwürfe der menschen müssen
wirtschaftlich umsetzbar sein
gleichzeitig darf man sie dich zwingen
etwas vorzugeben dass sie nicht sind sie
sollten ihre wünsche und ihre wahre
identität nicht verstecken müssen doch
die wende in unserer zivilisation
erschwert die bestrebungen das in
unseren gesellschaften alle akzeptiert
werden und gemeinsam agieren können ein
kulminationspunkt dieser krise zum das
europäischer sicht ist er der praxis und
das break ist verlangen in dem alle
strömungen die sie genannt haben fasst
zusammen kommen es gibt ein identitäts
bedürfnis es gibt die teilung zwischen
stadt und land und es gibt eine tiefe
strukturelle dysfunktionalität ein nicht
funktionierendes politischen systems wie
schätzen sie als anglo amerikaner als
kanal hat ja diese diese diese dieser
verfall dieser alten kulturellen
demokratie ein von drexhage sind
verschiedene bevölkerungsgruppen
betroffen da sind zb die bewohner der im
niedergang befindlichen alten
industriellen regionen im norden und
nordosten
sie sind überzeugt sie hätten es früher
besser gehabt sie leiden unter der
verschlechterung und haben den eindruck
niemand kümmere sich um sie deshalb sind
sie wütend auf die eliten aber den dreck
zieht befürwortern der tory partei geht
es um etwas anderes
sie pflegen einen sehr mächtigen mythos
ihr größter moment war als die briten
1940 allein gegen die deutsche übermacht
antrag
es gibt eine art kult und diesen moment
den wir auch die heutige generation aus
ihrer sicht verraten haben und den sie
zurückgewinnen wollen damit er her geht
die starke betriebene vorstellung dieses
von europa befreite vereinigte
königreich könne alles ach wir machen
deals mit der ganzen welt sogar mit
trump und dieser sagt gut aber über
lasst mir euer gesundheitssystem
das ist eine große selbsttäuschung es
gibt also verschiedene beweggründe
aber die praxis befürworter der tories
sind fanatisch geworden sie werden
auseinander brechen wenn sie unter druck
geraten zum beispiel durch ein
referendum das den verbleib in der eu
vor
und dann gibt es die jungen bewohner der
städtischen gebiete im südosten die
jammern weil sie ihre europäische
identität verloren haben
wenn wir darüber sprechen dass einer der
wichtigsten tiefsten demokratien des
westens in einer offenbaren krise ist
vielleicht können wir das von den usa
auch sagen kann
gibt es auch eine krise demokratie der
anerkennung in dem sinn dass man sagt
vielleicht gibt es andere
regierungsformen die funktional klüger
effektiver rationaler sind technokratin
wie in singapur oder vielleicht sogar in
china dass man sagt das mögen keine
vollkommen institutionalisierten
demokratien seien aber da passieren
wenigstens vernünftige dinge da werden
rationale entscheidungen getroffen
es gibt umfragen im westen die solche
tendenzen vor allem bei jungen menschen
aufzeigen
ich weiß nicht wie ernst ihre zustimmung
gemeint ist ich weiß nicht ob sie die
einschränkungen ihrer freihält und ihrer
rechte akzeptieren würden aber es ist
bedenklich dass viele leute finden
unsere demokratien würden nicht
funktionieren
ich denke das wollen sie damit sagen
wären sie aber die lieblings totaler
kontrolle durch die verschiedenen
überwachungsmechanismen ausgesetzt ich
glaube nicht dass sie das akzeptieren
würden vielleicht die singapurer aber
vergessen sie nicht singapur wurde lange
an einer sehr kurzen leine gehalten
inzwischen wurde diese ein wenig
gelockert
aber es gab dort einen kontrollierten
multikulturalismus eine erzwungene
gegenseitige anerkennung das ist eine
erfolgsgeschichte unter speziellen
umständen aber global gesehen haben wir
ja länder die sich in diesem übergang
befinden
länder wie die türkei länder die
einstmals russland länder wie jetzt
brasilien in denen das demokratische
system sich wie soll man das sagen
freiwillig selbst abschafft ja und nein
ich denke heute erleben wir eine andere
bedrohung der demokratie
die leute sprechen immer von den 1930 er
jahren von hitler mussolini stahl
sie sind keine gefahr mehr für uns
gefährlich sind die neuen demokratien
putins russland wurde erdogans türkei
genau das ist der punkt
sie wollen gewisse demokratische
errungenschaften beibehalten zum
beispiel ist ein teil der medien nicht
total unter ihre kontrolle
sie ermöglichen wahlen lassen auch
gewisse oppositionsparteien zu die sich
selbst darstellen dürfen aber sie sorgen
dafür dass sie ihre macht nie verlieren
und arrangieren die dinge entsprechend
ungarn ist ein weiteres beispiel dafür
ich nenne sie irreversiblen demokratie
sie gebärden sich ähnlich wie gewisse
regimes nach dem scheitern des
kommunismus wie ungarn mit seinem urlaub
kommunismus dort sagte man der
bevölkerung bleibt zu hause schreibt
eure bücher veröffentlicht nichts
gefährliches und wir behelligen euch
nicht was natürlich die wolke westen
früher getan haben
ja das ist wenn sie wollen eine sanfte
form von freiheitsentzug
man kann sogar alle vier jahre an die
urne gehen obwohl es nie gelingt einen
oppositionellen zu wählen
trotzdem sind solche regierungsformen
sehr verführerisch mehr als die
nachahmung des chinesisch
kommunistischen regimes sie sind denn
auch die wirkliche gefahr
diese irreversiblen seien demokratien
oder gelenkten demokratie
wie der indonesische präsident zu carlo
sie bezeichnete sie sind gefährlich also
nicht die 1930 er sondern die 2020er
jahre
diese demokratien ging mit einem
gewissen versprechen einher und es ist
mittlerweile hauptsächlich ein schutz
versprechen dass davor schützen soll das
fremde das ausländer dass migranten in
das land kommen
wir schauen uns dazu mal die meldung
eines der wichtigen menschen an des
papstes der sich genau in diesem sinne
vertrete demokratie geäußert hat hier
ist ja auch selber kompression die
kirche beobachtet mit wachsender
besorgnis das weltweite wiedererstarken
von aggressiven verhalten gegenüber
ausleihen seien besonders gegenüber
einwanderern
auch der wachsenden nationalismus der
das gemeinwohl vernachlässigt macht uns
sorge die art und weise wie eine nation
einwanderer empfängt zeigt ihr
verständnis von menschenwürde und ihr
verhältnis zur menschlichkeit
jedes menschliche wesen ist teil der
menschheit und hat dieselbe
menschenwürde wenn ein einzelner oder
eine familie gezwungen sind aus ihrer
heimat zu fliehen müssen sie mit
menschlichkeit empfangen werden war gold
agronom anita ein ganz klares bekenntnis
zur menschlichen würde auch als zentrum
einer demokratie aber gerade was die
stabilisierend wirkt ist ja derzeit die
aussicht dass zu viele menschen aus
anderen ländern die demokratien von
innen heraus zu die stabilisieren
drohnen zumindest ist das der eindruck
den manche menschen haben das ist
richtig schon immer lebten in einer
gesellschaft vor allem menschen eines
bestimmten schlags und gab es andere
waren sie schon sehr lange da wenn
fremde menschen angehöriger einer
unbekannten religion hinzu kamen fragte
man sich voller angst werden die uns
verändern können wir unsere identität
beibehalten
ich kann das vielleicht besser
nachvollziehen als viele nordamerikaner
weil ich als kritik stamme aus einer
gesellschaft die seit rund 250 jahren um
ihre identität kämpft im gepäck erlebten
wir das immer wieder
wir waren besorgt wegen der neuen
muslimischen gemeinschaft dass wir
katholiken protestanten juden unter uns
hatten war okay als sie hatten wir uns
gewöhnt doch dann kamen diese anderen
gruppen so etwas kann zur tragödie
werden aber wenn man nicht auf negative
feindliche weise eingreift ordnen sich
die dinge normalerweise von selbst in
unserem fall taten diese menschen alles
um sich in unsere reiche freie welt
einzugliedern
wenn wir sie fragten warum wollte bei
uns leben waren die beiden wichtigsten
argumente weil ich frei bin und meinen
kindern anders als in marokko oder
algerien eine ausbildung und eine chance
für ihr leben bieten
wie schaffen sie das sind sie die
patriotischen canaria oder bäcker und
beschämen uns damit unterbindet man
jedoch ihre bemühungen und greift sie an
in stehen tiefe wunden und entfremdung
problematisch ist dass die momentane
weltweite flüchtlingssituation uns
zwingt sofort menschen aufzunehmen
das ist ein großes problem aber man kann
immer noch gegen das falsche bild
kämpfen dass die meisten haben denn
diese angst führt zu den seltsamsten
stereotypen vorurteilen wie diese
muslime müssen alle terroristen seien
tatsächlich ist meistens das gegenteil
der fall
gegen diese vorurteile müssen wir
kämpfen auch wenn es schwierig ist
sie sind ja nun ein politischer
philosoph und man kann sagen dass
besteht eine gewisse spannung zwischen
der philosophischen forderung und der
politischen realität philosophisch sagt
man das sind menschen die sind ein wert
an sich sie haben als verfolgte ein
unbedingtes asylrecht politisch ist es
so dass es davon global so viele gibt
dass man nicht plausibel argumentieren
kann
diesem versprechen gerecht zu werden wie
manövrieren sie denn als denker
innerhalb dieser offenbaren spannung
das sind politische dilemma tal die man
nicht so einfach lösen kann
aber es gibt verschiedene womit man die
situation entschärfen
zuerst einmal kann man die bedingungen
in den flüchtlingslagern außerhalb von
europa verbessern und dafür sorgen dass
die kinder eine bessere ausbildung
bekommen damit sie wenn sie jemals dort
wegkommen nicht hoffnungslos
hinterherhinken
das sind mildernde maßen
es gibt keine einfachen schönen lösung
aber so ist es in der geschichte und in
der politik es geht darum das am
wenigsten inhumane zu tun
können sie denn vorschläge
beispielsweise von linken philosophen
dies hlawatschek nachvollziehen der sagt
wir müssen langsamer machen sonst die
stabilisieren wir die letzten
demokratien die an sich noch
funktionieren so weit dass dieser auch
instabil werden ich denke daran ist
etwas war und man kann es auch
beobachten die beiden großen
flüchtlingsströme aus afrika und dem
nahen osten sind zurückgegangen oder
versiegt aus libyen zu einem gewissen
grad und aus der türkei großenteils
gewissermaßen schließen parteien wie die
afg eine tür
aber sie sind alle besorgt wegen
zuständen die inzwischen passé sind
natürlich müssen wir verhindern dass die
flüchtlingssituation wieder diese
ausmaße annimmt
aber dann müssen wir uns gegen diese
parteien wehren und sagen diese menschen
sind nun mal hier
entweder macht ihr aus dieser situation
ein albtraum für alle oder wir schauen
wie wir zusammenleben können
ich denke dafür müssen wir kämpfen das
sage ich obwohl ich nicht europäer ihr
müsst gegen diese parteien kämpfen und
sie fragen was für eine zukunft bietet
ihr euren kindern und groß kindern in
euren tief gespaltenen gesellschaften
die nur mit hass und zurückweisung auf
diese einwanderer reagieren und damit
natürlich auch keine lösung anbieten für
die wirtschaftlichen probleme sie haben
nun als sofa ein extrem gutes gespür
eine art prophetisches gespür gehabt für
die konstellation in denen wir jetzt
stehen sie haben bereits in den 70er
jahren theorien darüber entwickelt die
nationalstaaten damit umgehen dass
mehrere ethnien mehrere kulturen in
diesem nationalstaat leben der begriff
den sie verankert haben im politischen
diskurs ist der multikulturalismus und
entstand aus einer sehr kanadischen
situation
gehören der französischsprachige
minderheit an und das war die frage wie
sich diese minderheit als kulturelle als
sprachliche minderheit halten wird
können wie sie ihr überleben als
gemeinschaft sich hat war das der
ausgangspunkt in kanada ist es noch
komplexer denn der multikulturalismus
ist eine politische lösung für eine sehr
breit gefächerte emigration in kanada
haben wir jedoch eine zwei nationen
politik wir haben eine französisch
sprechende nation in quebec und das
restliche land das ich mehr oder weniger
um die englische sprache gruppiert wir
hatten dadurch große probleme weil es
zeiten gab in denen sich koubek
unabhängig machen wollte und dann wieder
wollte mahnte beck nicht integrieren
wir scheinen diese spannungen wie durch
ein wunder club verfolgt überwunden und
eine übereinkunft gefunden zu haben
multikulturalismus hingegen ist die
politische lösung für eine gesellschaft
die eine große anzahl flüchtlinge
integriert nach dem grundsatz dass sie
nicht von den britischen inseln oder vom
norden frankreichs stammen müssen um wie
alle anderen vollwertige bürger zu sein
es ist eine politik der integration
ungeachtet der herkunft aber die
integration hat eine gewisse bremse denn
ihr zugang sagte integrieren euch aber
gleichzeitig gibt es das versprechen
dass sie ihre kulturelle identität als
gemeinschaft in diesem neuen land halten
bestärken könnt und dass der staat diese
sogar fördert die integration aber keine
assimilation
integration bedeutet dass man in der
gesellschaft verschiedene rollen
übernimmt
zuerst einmal bekommt man einen job und
kann seine kinder ernähren
man kann aber auch eine partei oder
vereinen beitreten und so teil der
gesellschaft werden ausgehend von
unserem gut fundierten grundsatz haben
wir folgende erfahrung gemacht wenn
menschen sich auf diese weise
integrieren entstehen gemeinschaften die
auf
und legen den kulturellen und
politischen werten gründen
das haben wir erlebt und das ohne den
gleichen glauben zu haben die einen sind
muslime die anderen christen oder
atheisten
sie sind so unterschiedlich wie man es
sich nur vorstellen kann
damit müssen wir leben keine
assimilation aber volle integration in
diesem prozess lässt man zu dass sich
das verhältnis zwischen kultureller
einheit und diversität von selbst regelt
ausgehend von der überzeugung dass
kulturelle unterschiede eine
bereicherung und keine gefahr darstellen
sie sprachen von integration und der
idee der integration setze voraus dass
es eine light bei einer heim kultur gibt
ihnen die man sich integriert hier sehr
interessanter ansatz dass multikulti
verbissen muss zeichnet sich nun dadurch
aus dass ist dieses versprechen einer
leitkultur in die man sich integrieren
kann gar nicht mehr explizit gibt und
damit wird er die idee der integration
selbst ein wenig heikel brüche
das ist etwas neues in der geschichte
sie haben recht und genau das bedeutet
multikulturalismus
er sieht keine leitkultur vor sondern
integration
die menschen bekommen arbeit und
übernehmen verschiedene rollen in der
gesellschaft so kommen sie einander
näher lernen sich kennen und arbeiten
zusammen
das führt nicht nur zu einer
soziologischen integration sondern zu
einem gegenseitigen austausch
hinzu kommt die kulturelle einheit
sie ist nicht viel anders als die
gemeinsame kultur die kanada schon immer
hatte sie beinhaltet politische ethik
und entwickelt sich mit den generationen
wie alles andere weiter aber mit dem
resultat dass wir einander so nahe
kommen dass die unterschiede als
bereicherung und nicht als gefahr
wahrgenommen wird
doch das gilt nicht für kimback denn im
englischsprachigen kanada stand nur ein
drittel der bevölkerung von den
britischen inseln
während in quebec etwa 75 prozent der
bevölkerung von den ursprünglich
siedlern am ufer des saint lawrence
stroms ab statt
dort gilt das prinzip der
interkulturalität also eine
kontrollierte neudefinition der kultur
das heißt die neu zugezogenen mischen
sich mit den ansässigen und schaffen
immer wieder neue zwischen kulturen
[Musik]
das ergibt eine kontinuität im verlauf
der geschichte die ständige veränderung
erfordert der enkel beck sogar davor
angst hat dem sage ich jeweils diese
immigranten verändern uns viel weniger
als unsere kinder und grosskinder wir
erleben also kontinuierliche sehr
komplexe und starke interne
veränderungen die aber vor allem durch
unsere kinder und grosskinder ausgelöst
werden also ein wandernder identitäts
horizont durch die zeit der sich immer
weiter erneuert und verändert aber ein
bedenken kann man ja trotzdem
formulieren
dieses multikulturalisten paradigma ist
für brust koloniale gesellschaften
besonders geeignet es hatte dann aber
eine globale karriere in deutschland in
finnland in schweden sagte man auch in
den 80er 90er jahren wir wollen eine
multikulturelle gesellschaft sein ohne
dass dafür die spezifischen
voraussetzungen gegeben gewesen wären
die im ursprung dieser idee in kanada
gegeben gewesen wären mich interessiert
wie haben sie dieses wandern dieses
konzept als globales konzept beobachtet
ja ja wir sind nun in diesem prozess
seit 200 jahren mit wir meine ich nicht
nur kanada und die usa sondern die ganze
westliche hemisphäre viele länder wie
peru und brasilien sind in dieser
situation
wir verstehen daher ziemlich gut wie es
funktioniert und erfolge aus der
vergangenheit ermutigen uns auch in
zukunft menschen zu integrieren
das ist im europäischen kontext
verständlicherweise nicht passiert und
deshalb sind die menschen sehr
verängstigt gewisse muster die wir als
vorübergehende phänomene kennen machen
den bürgern hier große angst
ein beispiel wer menschen aus einem
fremden land zu uns kommen finden sie
zueinander warum ich bin neu und finden
keinen job
was soll ich tun mein schwager hat einen
freund der die leute tun sich zusammen
weil sie sonst nur schwer überleben
können
das gleiche passiert in ländern wie
indien in mumbai wenn sie aus cucherat
kommen oder südindien dann mit freunden
ja das ist also kein grund zur sorge
die nächste generation macht das nicht
mehr die übernächste noch weniger denn
sie gewinnen freunde und haben jobs die
ihnen kontakte in anderen bereichen
ermöglichen
es ist also kein bleibendes sondern ein
vorübergehendes phänomen
wenn ich über multikulturalismus in
europa rede meinen die leute immer wir
verstünden darunter dass diese menschen
in ihrer ghettos gehen und uns nicht
mehr behelligen sollten gekoppelt mit
den tatsächlichen phänomen einer
gewissen ghettoisierung in amsterdam
oder andere ja es sieht aus wie der
beginn einer ghettoisierung doch der
lauf der dinge ist anders vorausgesetzt
man behält diese menschen nicht in den
ghettos man stigmatisiert sie nicht so
sagt ihr seid seltsam und gehört nicht
hierher
ich befürchte aber genau das tun die
franzosen mit ihrer jungen muslimischen
bevölkerung
ich hatte nun einmal das große vergnügen
auch nach kanada einzuwandern und ist
der grenzbeamte sagt sagte mir damals
ich werde es nicht vergessen wir kommen
kann da machen sie uns besser ein
wunderschöner satz für jeden der in ein
neues land kommt aber man hat mir auch
erklärt was multikulturalismus im
vergleich zum amerikanischen melting pot
ist und die sagten kanada ist wie eine
salatschüssel und die zutaten der
verschiedenen ethnien sind die zutaten
des salats die vermischen sich nicht
sondern die bleiben so wie sie sind das
heißt es gibt schon die idee dass es
dann irgendwann keine verschmelzung gibt
sondern eine beharrlichkeit der
jeweiligen kultur häufig dazu
ich denke das ist ein wenig illusorisch
auch eines schmeichelhaft klingen
wir denken ja gern wir seien besser als
die amerikaner
aber ich glaube nicht dass es stimmt die
realität in beiden ländern liegt
zwischen diesen beiden extremen in new
york hat sich vielmehr von der
ursprünglichen kultur erhalten und in
toronto viel weniger als die leute
meinen aber in diesem unterfangen in dem
unsere gesellschaften stecken und an dem
viele menschen aus unterschiedlichen
kulturen beteiligt sind sollten wir eine
gesunde mischung anstreben
eine gesellschaft in der es integration
gibt in dem leute jobs bekommen und sich
angehörige verschiedener kulturen
austauschen und es entstehen neue ideen
und neue kapazitäten im gepäck ist es
zum beispiel erstaunlich wie viele junge
leute englisch und französisch sprechen
viele kommen von anderswoher und bemühen
sich sehr das ist ein großer vorteil in
der heutigen zeit in der man mit
menschen aus der ganzen welt umgehen und
verhandeln muss unsere gesellschaft
verfügt also über talente für die andere
länder alles geben wird
bei der verbreiterung der möglichkeiten
trotzdem gibt es ja eine art politischen
dunklen bruder des multikulturalismus
der insbesondere von rechten und
identitäten parteien in europa namhaft
gemacht wird das nennt sich ethno
pluralismus und die idee ist ganz
ähnlich klingen die ihre intuition dass
sich gewisse kulturelle gemeinschaften
schützen müssen dafür davor dass sie
kritisiert verändert dynamisiert werden
und wenn sie das nicht aktiv tun dann
gehen sie als gemeinschaften und ich
denke es ist illusorisch zu meinen wir
könnten voneinander lernen und würden
uns stark von anderen beeinflussen
lassen
das sehe ich an mir selbst ich habe
andere sprachen gelernt und
fremdländische literatur gelesen und
fühle mich dadurch bereichert
aber ich bin nicht wie die autoren der
literatur die ich gelesen habe
ich bin sehr beeindruckt von der
polnischen literatur aber ich war nie
pole
es ist also eine illusion
aber gewisse leute verstehen nicht wie
interessant und fruchtbaren austausch
mit menschen sein kann die zutiefst
anders bleiben aufgrund ihrer herkunft
ihrer kulturellen bezüge
man kann darin sogar einen gewissen
vorteil sehen es anregend und bereich
und finden aber es geht niederung wie
sie zu werden
diese feier der pluralität und das ist
ja ein gedanke der ihr konzept trägt der
hat nun eine gewisse veränderungen
vorgenommen man kann sagen früher 80er
90er sprachen wir über
multikulturalismus heute gibt es ein
neues basso hat einen neuen kern begriff
der heißt diversität da geht es nicht
mehr um kulturelle gemeinschaften
sondern um sexuelle gemeinschaften um
andere formen des andersseins die auch
anerkennung wollen das hat aber mit
ihrem konzept einer kulturellen
verankerung gar nicht mehr so viel zu
tun
diese diversität ich denke es ist ein
breiteres konzept das alles umfasst was
multikulturalismus
dazu gehören auch andere bereiche wie
die sexuelle orientierung die gender
fragen aber es geht um die gleiche
philosophische einsicht dass eine
gesellschaft zum beispiel tolerieren
sollte das ich hetero bin und mein
freund homosexuell ist in so einer
gesellschaft kann ich viel lernen
die diversität mehr schätzen und gutes
über andere menschen erfahren ohne wie
die anderen werden zu müssen
ich denke sie haben nicht in unseren
modernen gesellschaften ist
multikulturalismus vielleicht eine
offizielle politik weil sie
vorgeschrieben ist
aber was den leuten wirklich zusagt ist
die diversität
manchmal sagt ein bild mehr als 1000
worte und es gibt ein wunderbares bild
das diese kanadische utopie
zusammenfasst das ist das bild des
ersten kabinetts ihres premierministers
tinto dass wir uns jetzt gerne mal kurz
anschauen können denn ist ein
paradebeispiel in dem multikulturalismus
und diversity zusammenkommen vielleicht
ganz kurz erklärt 50 prozent dieser
kabinettsmitglieder sind frauen
und man kann sehen dass fast jede form
kulturellen da seins abgebildet ist es
gibt menschen mit einer behinderung es
gibt menschen verschiedenen religiösen
hintergrund es gibt auch einen
homosexuellen oder eine lesbische
ministerin
das heißt alles ist abgebildet ist das
für sie ein idealbild wie menschliche
gemeinschaft funktionieren soll ja in
gewisser hinsicht
doch dieses bild ist vom fotografen
engagiert ich möchte eine gesellschaft
die sich natürlich ohne irgendwelches
eingreifen in vorständen parteien findet
man am runden tisch 50 prozent frauen
und menschen verschiedener orientieren
trio hatte die vorstellung wenn man die
gesellschaft so arrangiert wird sie in
diese richtung gehen und das geschieht
tatsächlich jetzt gibt es gerade aus der
richtung aus der sie politisch
philosophische kommen im kommunitarismus
viele menschen die sagen dieser drang
zur diversität der betonung einer
eigenen lokalen identität ich bin
zunächst einmal ein transgender personen
ich bin zunächst einmal eine frau ich
bin zunächst einmal an afroamerikaner
dass das eine schwächende wirkung mit
hinsicht auf das gemeingut hat das heißt
dass diese menschen sich mit einer
lokalen identität vereinnahmen lassen
ohne dass sie das große ganze dann noch
im auge haben können makler hat ein
ähnliches argument vorgebracht wie
würden sie das sehen gibt es ein zuviel
an diversität in dem das gemeinwohl den
ausblick weiter gerät wirklich wichtig
ist die frage ob man solidarität
schaffen kann unter menschen die
unterschiedliche stellungen bekleiden
und andere lebensentwürfe
nun gibt es bereiche in der diversität
die kompakt
denn unsere bemühungen um die akzeptanz
der diversität in unserer gesellschaft
haben neue bande zwischen
unterschiedlichen gruppen geschaffen
das habe ich selber erlebt ich habe in
québec gegen gesetze gekämpft die
islamischen frauen verbieten wollten den
ganzkörperschleier zu tragen und jobs zu
kriegen und ich fand mich in
demonstrationen neben einem nicht
gläubigen muslim einem agnostiker einen
katholiken einer protestanten einem
atheisten
wir waren sehr stark verbunden durch
unseren kampf gegen dieses gesetz
da gibt es also keine widersprüche
andererseits wird jedoch diese
authentizität seit kurzem durch ein
anderes schlimmes phänomen bedroht das
mit meritokratie zu tun hat jugendliche
die eine viel bessere bildung bekommen
haben als ihre eltern die erfolgreich
sind als manager usw sind überzeugt sie
hätten das ganz allein geschafft
das geht einher mit dem bedürfnis sich
zu verwirklichen was tödlich ist diese
haltung belastet das leben in unseren
demokratie die menschen die in sachen
solidarität führend sein sollten nämlich
die erfolgreichen die zu geld gekommen
sind und wichtige positionen bekleiden
die hacker bergs dieser welt wenn sie so
wollen zeigen sich kaum solidarisch mit
denen die es schwer haben also ein
eliten problem dieser abkoppeln in ihren
interessen der gemeinschaft richtig und
dagegen müssen wir mit allen mitteln
kämpfen
wie schafft man diese art von
solidarität nur durch politische
bewegungen die zum ziel haben solche
probleme zu überwinden und bessere
bedingungen für diese menschen zu
schaffen
in diesen bewegungen fühlen sich die
menschen stark und fähig etwas zu
bewirken
sie überwinden das gefühl der ohnmacht
sie schließen sich zusammen
wir müssen daher unsere haltung zu
einigen helden der digitalen welt wie
mark zuckerberg ändern
wir verdanken ihnen zwar durchaus einige
errungenschaften abgesehen von den damit
einhergehenden problemen
sie schaffen andere probleme weil sie
die steuer nicht oder auf den
cayman-inseln bezahlen oder sie
schaukeln die dinge so dass sie am
meisten profit in irland machen würde
die steuern tief sind das sind also sehr
schlechte bürger entsprechen jetzt die
hierarchie in sozialen beziehungen an
ungleichheit auch im sinne von monetärer
oder solidaritätsbekundung ein problem
an dieser diversität die manche menschen
als solches erfinden empfinden ist das
wenn eine person sich mit einer
gemeinschaft identifiziert die viel
schlimmes erfahren hat eine opfer
gemeinschaft sagen wir afro amerikaner
sagen wir vielleicht auch nur frauen im
dialog zwischen zwei menschen schleicht
sich dann oft auch eine hierarchie ein
in der gestalt dass man sich selbst als
weißer mann zum beispiel als täter fühlt
und es eine art schuld hierarchie gibt
zwischen der person die sich als opfer
gemeinschaft identifiziert und einer
anderen die vielleicht die täter
gemeinschaft ist oder als frage gestellt
dieses diversität beschrieben ziehen
sich da nicht auch hier agiert in das
soziale system ein
die schwierig zu bearbeiten sind denn
die leute am oberen ende der leiter sind
sich oft der realität nicht bewusst
sie haben den eindruck den schwarzen
geht es ziemlich gut aber mir geht es
besser weil ich weiß und schwarz sind
solche probleme können wir überwinden
und sie werden angegangen von bewegungen
wie black lips matter in den usa wie
mieter die vor allem die
missbrauchsfälle in den usa an den
pranger stellt schwierig ist es
gegenreaktionen zu verhindern
die von leuten in höheren positionen die
finden die leute sind okay so lange sie
bleiben wo sie sind und ich zuerst
einige sehr gute soziologische oder
anthropologische studien würde diese
geisteshaltung wurden von soziologen wie
ali hochschild gemacht dieses thema
müssen wir vertiefen
führen sie denn als politischer
philosoph auch sagen dass eine weiße
historisch begangenes unrecht als an
einer gemeinschaft dadurch wieder gut
gemacht werden kann dass man die
jetzigen vertreter dieser gemeinschaft
in gewisser weise besonders fördert oder
vielleicht sogar staatlich übervorteilt
indem man quoten einrichtet besondere
forderungsprogramm gibt es überhaupt
eine weise dieses unrecht in der
gegenwart adäquat auszugleichen ich
denke das ist möglich nicht weiß dass
der widerstand gegen solche bestrebungen
eingehend untersagt
viel wurde getan mit quoten für
afroamerikaner
nun gibt es allerdings wieder
gegenreaktionen das ist ein anderes
großes problem dass wir noch viel
stärker bekämpfen müssen aber da geht es
darum den angehörigen dieser first
nations wieder auf die füße zu helfen
damit sie ihr leben bewältigen können
vancouver ist gute arbeit geleistet
worden in dem die leute in den
aborigines gesetzen geschult wurden
da gibt es an den weg den wir gehen
können ich weiß es gibt immer noch
widerstand aber der wird abnehmen je
weiter wir diesen weg verfolgen
ein wichtiger aspekt ihres schaffens und
auch ihres daseins ist auch ihr glaube
sie sind ein gläubiger katholik und das
war für mich immer faszinierend zu sehen
wie ein mensch der sich zum katholischen
glauben bekennt die spannung zur
philosophie als philosophie ausgleich
wird da könnte ja sagen die beiden dinge
schließen sich fast aus dem katholischen
glauben geht es um dogma und dinge die
nicht hinterfragt werden können und in
der philosophie um die aktivität des
hinterfragen
der frau aber die philosophie mit thomas
von aquin zum beispiel der zwar nicht
meine richtung entspricht den ich habe
ein bewunderer ich orientiere nicht mehr
an der phänomenologie an hussel oder
rica ich denke heute gibt es in der
katholischen kirche und allen großen
glaubensgemeinschaften ein bewusstsein
für die vielfalt der philosophischen
ausdrucksweisen für den glauben
das hängt zusammen mit etwas das zentral
ist für das einundzwanzigste jahrhundert
nämlich verschiedenste
annäherungsversuche an den glauben an
das zentrale verstehen der christlichen
kirche das ist sehr hilfreich für uns
fehlt heute der zugang zu einer tiefen
spiritualität die den menschen früher
halt gab
ich komme von tepic marie der lanka
nation war eine wichtige frau die man
völlig vergessen hat wegen des
widerstands gegen die katholische kirche
aber es gibt leute die neue initiativen
ergreifen wie xavier der gemeinschaften
gegründet hat in denen behinderte und
nicht behinderte menschen zusammenleben
das ist eine neue art von apostolischen
werk aber auch eine neue verbindung zur
zentralen botschaft des christentums
das ist das spannende an der heutigen
zeit einerseits gibt es viele
kirchenaustritte von gläubigen menschen
andererseits entstehen diversifizierte
wege zum glauben die man vergessen hat
oder die es bisher nicht gab
verboten der philosophie um james hat
eine religiöse erfahrung ist so wichtig
dass sie die heisse stelle in unserem
bewusstsein verschickt es ist ein neues
zentrum der identität und mir scheint
dass gerade im amerikanischen discos
oder amerikanischen diskurs ist ein sehr
unglückliches verhältnis gibt zwischen
menschen die auf religiöse menschen als
geistig minderbemittelt oder gerade zur
effizienten gesehen weil sie die
wissenschaft haben eine art
vulgarisierung des verhältnisses
zwischen religion und wissenschaft die
auch in die philosophie immer stärker
anzieht
es zeigt sich verstärkt in einer
bestimmten philosophischen richte
andererseits gibt es leute die diese
sehr enge naturwissenschaftliche
betrachtung des menschen die keine
zukunft hat dekonstruieren
und es gibt wissenschaftler wie john
will beck die begriffe wie die cnc in
einem weiteren zusammenhang sehen und
eine beziehung zum religiösen glauben
herstellen ich denke darüber könnten wir
endlos diskutieren aber es geht immer
weiter und wir bleiben dran
aber wenn die heute das team haben die
suche nach einer perfekten gemeinschaft
nach einem perfekten zusammenleben dann
könnte ein zentraler gedanke wenn man
auf die weltkarte heute schaut sein der
hauptgegner
das haupthindernis solch einer
gelungenen zusammenlebens sind religiöse
überzeugungen
das ist das wo menschen gegeneinander
auf leben und tod aufeinander zugehen
wenn man mit heute 2020 wenn man damit
das zwanzigste und einundzwanzigste
jahrhundert meint müsste man stalin
hitler pol pot dieser kategorie zuordnen
hilfe zählen wir jetzt die leichen doch
wenn wir einen vergleich anstellen
würden wäre die zahl der von atheisten
verursachten opfer mindestens so groß es
ist ja kein wettbewerb an dem wir uns
beteiligen wollen
wir stehen ja derzeit unserer
weltgemeinschaft das ist ja auch ein
schönes wort das es noch gar nicht so
lange gibt vor einer neuen
herausforderung insbesondere der
ökologischen heraus oder man hat das
gefühl dass derzeit ein neues
gemeinschafts bewusstsein globaler weise
sich entfaltet würden sie das teilen
dass die ökologische bedrohung uns einen
neuen sinn dafür geben kann was es heißt
an einer weltgemeinschaft schon möglich
auf jeden fall
ich bin sehr besorgt und aber angst denn
viele menschen meiner generation
scheinen das nicht ernst zu nehmen und
dann kommt er ein teenager wie greta
thunberg das ist toll
sie mobilisiert alle diese jugendlichen
die jeweils freitags die schule schmiss
diese generation könnte uns retten
etwas im menschlichen geist ist also
noch nicht abgestorben obwohl alte hasen
wie ich ihre verantwortung nicht
wahrnehmen
bei aller sympathie für diese bewegung
kann man sagen jetzt zentral des
momentes angst und angst es nicht
unbedingt ein faktor der solidarität
erleichtert sondern solidarität spaltet
dieses apokalyptischen bewusstsein wir
könnten die letzte generation sein die
überhaupt noch eine lebenswerte erde
vorfindet die muss ja gar nicht dazu
führen dass man zusammenkommt sondern es
könnte ja menschlich vielleicht sogar
plausibler dazu kommen dass man sich in
diesem apokalyptischen bewusstsein
es kommt sogar noch schlimmer wenn man
diese angst schuld
ich sitze vor dem fernsehen schaue mir
ein entsprechendes programm an bekomme
es immer mehr mit der angst zu tun und
weiß nicht was ich machen kann also
wechsle ich zum hobby spiel
die menschen zacken weg weil sie so
große angst haben dass greta thunberg
und andere jugendliche uns anbieten ist
ein gemeinsames projekt mit dem
aufregenden ziel
da eine welt zu schaffen in der wir
leben wollen es geht um mehr als von der
fossilen energie wegzukommen
wir können mehr bäume pflanzen und viele
solche dinge tun und damit etwas
erreichen
sie haben die kraft ein programm zu
schaffen das in den usa
green new deal heißt grün weil damit der
planet gerettet werden soll
odile weil es alle menschen umfasst die
sich durch die globalisierung und
roboter sierung im stich gelassen fühlt
beides ist gut miteinander vereinbar
denn der grüne bereich erfordert andere
investitionen in neue bereiche
ich gehe also davon aus dass die leute
begeistert sind davon also der eine
mischung zwischen technologischem
fortschritt und ökologischer erneuerung
die zusammenfinden können das wäre ihre
version wirklich genau das stelle ich
mir früher
deshalb frage ich mich wann die
politischen klassen in europa vor allem
in deutschland aus ihrer lähmung auf
wenn wir in diese richtung gehen
bekommen wir mehr stimmen von der afg
wenn wir diese richtung einschlagen
verlieren wir stimmen
sie sind gelähmt was sie brauchen ist
die lancierung eines neuen programms
vielleicht können sich die grünen und
die sozialdemokraten zusammen
für die erde genau das sollte die
menschen wachrütteln
aber sie sind völlig gelähmt wie das
kaninchen vor der schlange weg aus
dieser parallelisierung gibt es viele
einer ganz zentraler ist gottvertrauen
die idee dass auch wenn wir keine lösung
sehen er ist eine art vorsehung gibt die
das lösen wird spielt es in ihrem
eigenen leben für sie eine wichtige
rolle
das sieht man an der tatsache dass diese
jungen menschen auftreten und uns sagen
ihr seht wie es um die welt steht und
ihr tut nichts
für mich ist das gnade
das wäre es ist sichtbare effekte
passierte also die hoffnung auf eine
perfekte gemeinschaft führen sie sagen
ist letztlich eine von gott inspirierte
hoffnung in religiöser spur
die perfekte gesellschaft werden wir nie
haben wir ja das wird von uns gefordert
und mehr als dass uns dieser
herausforderung zu stellen klickt
unserem leben eine dimension die es
sonst nicht hätte verkehr was die
menschen sie sind sicher jemand der
diese dimension freigelegt hat bedacht
hat ausgearbeitet hat für uns für uns
alle
ich danke ihnen sehr dass sie heute da
waren und verabschiede mich auch gerne
von ihnen liebe zuschauer bis zur
nächsten sternstunde denken sie weiter
danke
[Musik]